[Music]
chris is with us cleveland ohio hi chris
what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call i'll
try to be as brief as possible um
my question is my wife and i over the
last two and a half years have really
focused in on the steps
and have been in the situation where now
we financially were able to pay off the
house
last fall
we have no credit card debt
and it seems to me at this point where
our income levels are she had recently
gotten promoted about two years ago
that now we're getting just absolutely
at the end of the year crushed and
having to write big checks for taxes
and i guess my question is i mean is is
potentially looking into
an llc with some rental properties even
something that should be on the table to
even look at
well an llc doesn't change the taxes at
all you can own the rental property in
your personal name
yeah well tax wise it doesn't change the
taxes one bit protection wise it's good
to put rental property in there from a
risk management standpoint somebody
falls and breaks their face
on that property then they can sue only
the owner of that property which happens
to not be you have to be an llc so they
don't come take your personal vehicle so
from a risk management standpoint i no
longer own anything
i'm completely poor
a company that i own owns everything you
know so i've got this stack of llc's
it's ridiculous my cars are even owned
by llc's now so uh but that's just
because you know i'm now i'm at a point
that i'm a target for lawsuits
uh because it's like oh dave ramsey
bumped into my car
you know so it's easier than winning the
lottery
who needed a job so um anyway but you're
not gonna quite be that way with one
rental property of course we're gonna
tell you to pay cash for the rental
property or not buy it and don't do
things
that don't make economic sense only for
tax reasons
okay and if you get tired of paying
taxes and mad about paying taxes like i
have and like you are
you can go that way
and i have found myself tempted to enter
into things that really don't make any
sense except the fact that they are a
huge tax write-off
and so i i don't do i would rather just
give it a charity and then you can write
it off
you know then i would go lose it and do
something bogus that gets me in a bind
later
in order to get a write-off so as long
as you're paying cash for the rental
yeah throw it in an llc for risk
management doesn't change taxes same
depreciation schedule either way it's
all passed through on an llc it still
lands on your personal return doesn't
change the stinking thing as far as that
goes but yeah it's okay to start talking
about doing that um and it is one of the
benefits of owning some real estate and
i'd talk with a tax pro if you don't
have one already you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com but working with one
of those elps they can look at your
whole situation and go oh here's a spot
you missed here's a spot we can save you
on taxes here's how to lower your
taxable income so that could help if
you're not already working with a pro
yeah and this idea that the rich don't
pay taxes
um
is 98 hogwash
i pay so much in taxes i can't breathe
i pay more in taxes
in a year than i made in the first 10
years of my working life wow i mean so
the idea that rich don't pay taxes
absolutely and i'm really good at this
stuff so it's just asinine that you know
well warren buffett's secretary pays at
a higher rate than he does yeah he lives
off capital gains which is a 15 rate
but it's 15 of a billion
and he's not he the only thing he has
are investments he has no earned income
only investments
so at a higher rate yes but the
secretary doesn't have a billion dollars
that she's living off of
and so she's paying ordinary income so
that's just a bogus argument too well
that's not fair it's absolutely fair
it's the tax code
sorry boys and girls